I am hoping that this is the right place
for this
I am streaming I believe but who knows
what is true
I do not
but the music is nice
and the mood is right
and my internet is stable I think this
is correct
I believe so
hello
hello everyone
as you can probably tell my voice is a
little bit short and I am a little bit
tired
so it is very good to see you
I have
a red hand of common Creator Clash
and I have
many things to share with you and I will
share them immediately
yes
this is not mark
I believe you are wrong
I believe you are wrong about that
I am me and who else could I be
I've started usually
I've
my voice is gone mostly just because I
was screaming yesterday
uh I was at the Creator Clash two if you
didn't catch it I was uh with Mr
jacksepticeye
um sorry if the music is imbalanced and
I'm a bit quiet I'll try to be a little
closer
but I was doing the pre and post show
and also I was at Creator Clash two
um and so I'll probably talk a little
bit about that but uh I'll also talk a
little bit about
the other things that have been immense
pieces of stress in my life but not
stress in a in a terrible woe is me way
stressing a uh
fascinating experiment of delicious and
Beautiful Moments that are wrapped in uh
arduous journeys of self-discovery
so
yes there are good stressors and there
are bad stresses and sometimes the good
stress can seem like a bad stress at the
time and it can all be wrapped up in an
enigma of unfavorable stresses
but for now I just want to get some uh
time in with you guys I did get some
sleep don't worry I took a four hour nap
yes I was going a little bit crazy and
for those of you who don't know what the
Creator class Ethan was fighting
um and he did very well
I am very proud of him uh it was a it's
an exciting night there were many things
to talk about it
um and there were many things to love
about it
um but for now I just wanted to inform
you and update you guys on the various
things and also just chat for a bit
I don't think that we've had an
opportunity to talk for a while and then
his uh
it has been a little bit it's been
incredibly busy there's um
excuse me
there's been a lot of things on my
played in a lot of things on my mind and
a lot of things that have been happening
that are incredibly exciting and none of
which that I have shared with you
and that is a problem that I've been
trying to address
um very recently but the reality of it
is often that uh when I get swept up in
these creative Endeavors and I I um
excuse me
I've I've thrashed my voice from
screaming for Ethan and the various
other Fighters uh last night he was
performing admirably and it was a very
tense fight
and uh I um
I'm very proud of how I did but that's
not what I was talking about what I was
talking about
is the uh movie that I've been working
on and obviously I've been talking on
and off about it for the better part of
a month and a half maybe even two months
now time kind of blurs together after a
while
um but with this one
and I was uh
definitely
putting more into it than I thought I
ever would
um so yes I've been working on a movie
we've been filming it for the past uh
four weeks plus obviously the
pre-production was
a while I've been working on it for
quite a while and that's why regular
videos have not been continuing for
quite a while no it's not the FNAF movie
it's my movie
um and it's something that I am I'm very
very proud of and it's something that
has taken a lot more work than
previously thought but at the same time
it's something that's going to be
infinitely more rewarding than I thought
before
I think that uh I think that you guys
are going to really really be surprised
when you see it and I want to tell you
that you are going to see something of
it very very soon we've kept things
under wraps
um but I've been working on a teaser
trailer well
basically done it just needs a little
bit more
um and it is
all all will be revealed
um all will be revealed
I'm hoping
at the end of this week I'm hoping
either Thursday or Friday or on the
weekend
there will be something for you all to
see
and it's not gonna be what you expect
I know for a fact it's not gonna be
anything close
to what you expect
um the you you know me I've always been
big about soundscapes and and work on
sound and one of the things that the
projects that I've had so far with like
Heist and space they've had incredible
sound because of the talented people
behind it and the Brad the sound
engineer working in post-production just
really really really really excited
and no well the trailer yes I'll post
the the trailer on my channel but the
movie itself no
you're going to see that in theaters
um and that's something that because of
the level of quality that this is uh
shaping up to be it is
it's just something
it's the culmination of all of my
like skills that I've built over a very
long period of time
at the right time and right place and
with the right idea
it's uh
yeah it's it's kind of one of those
things where yes that that is how this
is going to be
um
and it's just
is it PG-13
uh
let's go no
um
but it's uh yeah it is just like it's a
fascinating fascinating endeavor
and I'm really really
really excited about it
it's it's worth it uh the the knights
have been you know not enough sleep and
the days have been long
um and it always has been with the other
projects that I've done but I think this
one in in particular has demanded a lot
more of myself than I I imagined but
it's kind of like
you know it's kind of like when you were
passionate about something you just you
have to throw yourself into it
um hopefully not to the point where it
destroys you and I don't think that I'm
there yet
um but this definitely is the hardest
thing I've ever done
and I think I'll be the most proud of it
when it is out yeah so hopefully there
will be a trailer later uh today but
anyway I just wanted to give a moment to
uh talk to you guys to see whatever you
wanted to talk about
uh
yeah
um Ethan one yes yes absolutely yeah
is it going to be in in movie theaters
uh yeah
actually yeah
that's that's the craziest thing about
all this
um it's
that's why it's one of those things
where you know you you kind of just like
keep making something in a vacuum for a
very very long time and you get used to
this this style of putting things
um
putting things out there uh just because
you love making it and and this is no
different this has never been any
different for me I'm making this and
I've I've been making this just because
I love making things and I love I love
crafting things and I love content
Creation in general and and for me a
movie is is no different than any of the
other ones it's just in the way of
making it definitely
definitely a lot different is it related
to FNAF in no way in absolutely no way
is this related to FNAF at all
um I hate to break it to you guys but
it is uh it is absolutely not
definitively no
you'll you'll see and you'll get
everything about the genre and whatnot
you'll see uh when the trailer comes out
you will
SQL to space No it's it's also nothing
to do with any of my past projects at
all now this is this is different when I
say that it's different I mean that
um
but it's still very much I think I think
when you watch it you'll see it's like
still very much me it's just me applying
uh skills in a format that I've never
done before yeah
a sneak peek of the trailer you have to
wait
it's only a week more
it's only a week I'm I'm most excited
about the music though like the person
who's working on the music because it's
like we're making an original score for
the entire thing and it's
like it's wonderful
I can't even play any of it for you but
I listen to it every day
that's the the person making it is just
like incredibly excited about it and
just like incredibly talented and the
kind of like
different different Vibes that he's able
to craft up is is just like oh
it's it's beautiful
The Haunting and beautiful is wonderful
yes
yeah yeah
do more few food reviews yeah I would
love to get back into the reviews and
getting regular videos up and stuff like
this
um but today I flew back in from Creator
Clash this morning and I flew to Creator
Clash yesterday morning
um so sleep is not something that I have
had a lot of but had to be there I was
originally supposed to be at the first
grader Clash I'm not not as a fighter
definitely not but I was at least
supposed to be there
um but I was working on the
post-production of space and I think
that's like a habit of of everything
that I've I've done is I um I just
constantly throw myself into projects
again and again and it's it's it's
catching up to me a little bit is
catching after me
um but I couldn't couldn't say no to
this one it was uh very important
that they get there love in the 40 Hertz
voice yeah I was screaming a little too
much yesterday screaming uh just louder
than I ever have I was just very excited
yeah
you want to see it now too bad you have
to me I won't make vids anymore where
did I say that
in what world did I say that
and absolutely not
um I or absolutely I will be making
videos again
um it's just like this one has taken so
much time and I've wanted to make videos
while I was doing this it's just that
time gets away from me because I've had
to keep up with the podcast and that's
the one thing that I could say if you've
been missing out on regular video
content of me uh don't worry I've
actually been uploading three times a
week regular content with distractible
and go my favorite sports team it kind
of got swept under uh the rug because of
everything else I've been working on
um but I I partnered with Spotify I got
a deal with Spotify uh not for
exclusivity of the podcast in general
because the podcast is still available
all over the place but now video Bob
Wade and I in video format are now on
Spotify exclusively so you can go to
Spotify and you can see videos that's
where those clips if you've seen me
talking about ADHD and my experiences
with ADHD that's been going around on
Twitter and stuff and people have been
asked like oh where's where's this Cliff
from where is he talking about that's
distractible we now have video and we've
been doing video so the recording that I
have been doing
um has been with my friends and that's
then the thing that's keeping me sane uh
and at the same time I have been wanting
to record other videos but it's just
like
oh man it's it's uh it's going crazy but
I will be getting back to it so if you
want to go to Spotify and you look at
distractible and you want to get more
videos also we've been doing two
episodes of distractible a week on there
yeah
but I would go uh I'll go watch that if
you're missing out on some of that and I
will come back to YouTube in the very
very near future to be able to uh make
content again we are almost done with
filming we're almost done with filming
it is one of the longest uh film
schedules so far just because of the
complexities
like woven into this
um but man
this is really cool
I was really happy about it
give us a hint of what it's about you're
gonna see everything all of your
questions are going to be answered when
the trailer drops and it's coming later
this week so all of these questions
about the specificity of it will be
answered uh when the trailer
gets over there you'll see everything
you'll know exactly what this is about
yeah
um
how am I feeling today very tired I am a
crumbs
oh just the crumb no absolutely not
no no no you've waited this long you can
wait another week I mean I'm the same
way I want to drop this trailer
immediately
um but I just needed a little bit of VFX
help in it and then we need to like
finalize a few things in there that kind
of hold it off and make it really really
important it's like I want to make sure
that when this gets out there that it's
it's locked in and it's very tight but
one of the things that I've been doing
differently about this project as as
opposed to the Past projects is we've
had like obviously pictures and behind
the scenes but this time we've had a
dedicated person whose only job is to
document the entire process of creation
from start to finish of the movie so
there's just a wealth
of behind the scenes content for you to
consume that you will be getting very
soon did I get a haircut does it look
like I've gotten a haircut no way I've
not gotten a haircut
yeah no I'm good
lore yes or no what is it is that even a
question I don't even know what that
means
you know I don't even know what that
means am I done filming no two more
weeks or so
maybe a little more I have no idea
definitely not less
yeah
am I singing in it no no no
am I the code or it no I'm I'm the
director it's something that I wrote
um uh obviously I'm like there's help
behind it but you know just like this is
this is um this is my directorial debut
in terms of uh this is my big
like okay you know there's it's a
terrible reference
but for those of you who remember uh
Buenas honest uh we were making we were
making food out of Play-Doh and it just
turned into this big log and Ethan just
slaps it on the table oh wipe it up
[Laughter]
because I was screaming yesterday at
Creator class
um that that's me with this movie to the
rest of um basically the film industry
to be like hey
uh
uh here's what I can do
and here's why you should pay attention
to what I'm doing and at the very same
time I'm also going to be saying also I
don't need you in any way
to make what I want to make and to get
what I want to make out to people
if you know me you know that I'm kind of
driven by [__] you energy
and there's been just this storied
history
of people who are established in
Creative spheres not treating internet
content creators with the respect that
they deserve it's not even just me I
don't care one way or another if someone
acknowledges or gives legitimacy to what
am I I do I don't need them to give any
legitimacy but with this I'm going to
stick my foot I'm gonna stick my
Play-Doh dick in the door and then force
them to show like see I'm going to rip
their eyes open and show them that there
is a whole new world of content creation
coming for them and if they don't change
and adapt
I will just keep making it and I will
just keep putting it out there and it
will just keep storming over the things
that they make
and I'm not leading the charge or
anything it's just a reality
of individuals being able to make things
and it's a very exciting time
and that's a little part of what I'm I'm
making it for but you know there's also
that element to it you know
space was nominated for an Emmy like
that's that's a testament to the kind of
uh things that content creators on the
internet and I'm not the first one to be
nominated from I mean I did not even the
first one to like be nominated for
awards but it's like
it's getting too hard to ignore
so if they don't it's like an adapter
die situation
you know old old ways can become extinct
very quickly
um am I doing all of my own stunts uh
I'm doing the vast majority of my stunts
um just to tell a little bit about it
there was um one stunt in particular
that was particularly uh sketchy and so
there was a stunt double on the day and
he was he was in the scene first just to
test it and get something uh to see if
it was like just in case I didn't want
to do it so said the stunt coordinator
who's a very nice guy but at the same
time after he did it the stunt guy did
it and he was like
yeah that really hurt I win okay now my
turn
and so I did that and and man that was a
gnarly one uh the first you know we
start at 50 energy on some of those
things and you know it's 50 speed and I
do it and it goes I go
I'm just like all the air gets knocked
out of my lungs
all right let's go to 75 percent
it's just it's uh so we go 75 percentage
it's like wiring it's just
when you see it in the movie You're
Gonna Know instantly which one I'm
talking about
you're gonna instantly know
um but then it's wiring it I'm just like
I'm just like oh all right okay but I'm
in one piece and I'm okay
and so I go all right
we did that we got that one let's I feel
good I feel strong let's go one step up
let's get to a hundred percent
let me tell you
yeah
that one hurt that one hurt real bad
I found her really bad
man that was nuts that was nuts yeah
um
so my my back was a little a little
[__] up for a bit but I did it and
then I was like let's not do that again
as that was one was enough I I think we
got it I think we got it on that take
um but yeah no big respect to stunt
people and it's not an ego thing I
basically told the stun coordinator like
it's not an ego thing I just I would
never want to put someone through
something that I wasn't willing to go
through myself
um even though they went first and it's
just like I I also am like if this isn't
safe you know I'm not gonna like step up
and be like yeah because the problem is
like if I get hurt then it stops so much
stuff
um but it was it was very very
very cool like the the finished shot of
that stun is going to be really fun I
can't wait for that
that's gonna be oh man this this movie
is gonna be so fun
so fun
really really cool stuff can't wait for
you to see it
yeah
anyway anything else you guys would like
me to talk about besides me rambling on
about other things and [__] you energy
to people you know in other fields
because I could talk about that all day
how
where was that there's a question here
I lost it I lost it talk about Creator
Clash well I mean I could talk about
Creator Clash I'll do a go my favorite
sports team episode with Tyler we did
one
um before the clash and then I'll do one
wrapping up after the class because
Tyler was also there uh Creator Clash
um and that was that was a really fun
experience and it was just like it was
it's a really really cool event you know
and I know that influencer boxing is
kind of kind of memed on a lot but it's
like that they kind of embrace the meme
with this event and it is for charity
it's it's a very special occasion and I
think I think it is I think it is just
really cool
um feel bad for Ian though
um it was a it was really tough
obviously extremely stressful to
organize an event like that and then to
also participate in something it's
something that I can relate to and what
I do
um with like the the bigger projects
that I have
uh and it's it's just like it's really
really good Chris Ray Gun Fight yeah I
think the Chris ray gun fight was called
early I do I wasn't going to say that in
the in the post show or pre-show because
again I am always for safety but I think
that one was really really an early call
um
Chris I talked to him afterwards he was
totally fine
um he he was even surprised by it
however he did I don't know if I
couldn't hear the ringside commentators
um so I don't know if they were talking
about I don't know if people at home
caught it but he did Wallop the referee
which I think is like if it wasn't early
called and there was a little bit of
karma there
so I think that's that's uh that's only
fair as the only CEO of cloak any plans
yes I do have many plans once I'm done
filming here I want to do some
collaboration videos with
say um like fashion forward YouTubers
because cloak is shaping up to be
something that actually uh is starting
to push itself into like fashion and
stuff like that which is interesting
it's a fascinating world and it's also
something and I am very ignorant enough
so I don't ever want to do anything from
a place of ignorance so I always want to
feel like if I am going to be moving
forward or something
um it has to be
we're in with like the best intention of
him in mind and no disingenuousness
behind it it has to be something that's
going to be uh going forward
style Theory and cloak I'm assuming
that's a Channel of some kind
yeah and there's there's a lot of
various things moving forward with cloak
that you know you never thought that it
would come in a direction like that
because for five years we've been
working on it and now it's like growing
into something that's
that other people you know all that all
the time of even at Creator Clash other
influencers were like telling me like
man cloak is killing and I'm like yeah I
guess and and then I see more people
wearing cloak and I see like people with
enjoying it and I really love some of
the pieces that we've been making so
something that I realized like I cannot
treat something like that casually and I
never like to treat anything like that
casually
um because when there's an opportunity
to do something really really well and
it's not like we've been doing it poorly
it's just like if it has to evolve then
I have to learn and I have to be ready
for it because if I'm not ready for it
then it's just going to it's it's going
to seem false and it will seem fake so
it has to come from a place of true
growth and true learning and that's
that's how I approach everything I do I
would never want to walk into a field
that I didn't know
um either at least I didn't feel like I
knew extremely well
sorry my like I've said before probably
people chiming in my voices thrash
because I was screaming yesterday
yeah it's the same reason why when I'm
I'm talking a lot about like ADHD or
when I was talking about on distractible
and that clip was going around that I
was talking about before
um I've been wanting to do
I've been wanting to do a video talking
about my experiences with ADHD and like
what I think about it and how I think it
could help people but I wanted to do the
research required because even though
I've lived in I've only lived it and I
have not necessarily gone to school for
him and I haven't gone to school for
um like
understanding the Neuroscience behind it
and things like that so I wanted to
bring on guests because the only things
I could talk about are my experiences
with it and my struggles and the ways
that I've tried to ameliorate some of
the more difficult things and how I have
still moved forward with being able to
pursue creative Pursuits and things that
require a lot of concentration and skill
and like my experiences with medication
like going from starting with ritalin
and then moving to Adderall and now I'm
moving to a starus which is a newer drug
and the struggles with like even getting
these medications sometimes and the
stigmas behind it and the kind of like
misunderstandings and misinterpretations
about it and why I would prefer one over
another but without trying to like but
there's a danger in that because it's
not like I'm trying to push medication
so it's like that's my experience and
there are other there's other reasons
why people would want to not her take
medication it's like a complicated thing
I never want to speak from a place of
yes the CVS struggles yeah absolutely
and there's there's there's reason why
I'm I I don't like to bring things out
until they're ready until it's time
until it has its moment which is why the
trailer you can wait a week for it you
can do that
um
but it's just like it's it's uh like a
very balanced thing it's and it's also
very individualized because I may have
been taking one medication for a while I
was not Medicaid for a while and then I
switched to a new medication a star so
that I like more because it's it it
doesn't
this is me getting into the nitty-gritty
of it all but it's like it helps me
sleep better and sleep deprivation is
one of the biggest problems with uh some
other like medications they're just like
they they don't make you feel like
yourself and stuff like that and and so
the reasons why some people are hesitant
to take medication with ADHD is because
they hear this rumor that like it
stifles your creativity and like that is
a big fear even someone on set of the
movie has come up and talked to me about
it about they worry about taking
medications they feel safe with
creativity it's like yes I would
understand that concern and I I
personally am like the offset is that
you can do more
um but at the same time is it like it
you know it's it's hard to say it's hard
for me to speak to any one person's
individual things
um
I will will I play Five Nights at
Freddy's plus I don't even know what
that is
what is that
officially licensed and published under
the fan Fazbear fan verse initiative I
don't know anything about that
I don't know anything I don't know
anything about the FNAF movie don't ask
me anything about the FNAF movie my God
the things that I could definitely not
tell you about the FNAF movie that I
definitely don't know about
wink
I don't know anything or do I
question no
I know nothing
I know absolutely nothing
I know zero
I know very very nothing
about it
hmm
anyway
use FNAF to promote distractible right
okay so there was an episode of
distractible
where we talked at length about the Five
Nights at Freddy's movie and if you go
to distractible you can find all the
information that I've leaked and that I
am under legal trouble to disclose
not disclose
but there's also nothing there
you know what I've
look if you guys are gonna keep bugging
me about it I'm gonna just mess with you
from that time because obviously I don't
know anything about it
yeah obviously
I mean legitimately there is an episode
of distractible where we talk about the
article that was written because when
the Spotify deal was uh announced there
was a variety interviewed me and they
asked me a bunch of questions about it
in distractible in podcasting of my
philosophy on on You Know audio in
general and then at the very end of the
interview was like you know there's
rumors you're going to be in the FNAF
movie and I believe my wording was uh
something ambiguous because it caught me
off cards like oh yeah well no but there
was a I have nothing to say about it you
know there was scheduling conflicts
which everyone took to be like
oh
all right
so you know I I have absolutely nothing
nothing to say about it
nothing
nothing this is the wink is so you know
I'm telling the truth
right
okay cool
good good
all right I'll give you one chance I'll
give you one chance let's just say let's
just say for example let's say for
example that uh I knew everything
let's say for example I knew everything
about it
let's say what question would you ask
someone that just so happened to know
everything about it
is this a leak one though
[Music]
no
absolutely not
was that the point of things
foreign
maybe that was the bite of 87.
oh my God
was that The Bite of 87
wow
that's a that's um that's a definitely a
line in the movie maybe you'll never
know what's true or not
does he come back
what do you know that I don't know
an average
yes yes yes yes yes
you know
who's who's he
all the quote right right the I always
come back the rizzler
um
oh my goodness yeah anyway so
I uh
you guys are getting ahead of yourselves
in terms of the worldwide release
um
hold on about that I don't know let me
get the movie done first does Freddy
have a romance
[Music]
listen I uh I can't speak to anything
specifically about
how many sex scenes there are in the
FNAF movie
I'll just say that the rating of the
movie has yet to be finalized they
they're trying to work around
to not slip into an X rating
um
it's it's going to be somewhere between
PG
and it's rated
depending on how gratuitous it really is
but there's at least one right
look I can't say uh
there was some scheduling conflicts
about the number of sex scenes
so I can't say one way or another and I
hope you guys don't take this out of
context because that would be really
embarrassing for me uh who knows nothing
about it wink
um because I I don't know it's it's like
it's Scott's artistic vision and who am
I to question the number of
sex scenes he wants to put in the FNAF
movie who am I to question that
full frontal Freddy
uh
oh my gosh
in other words full frontal Freddie are
gonna be stuck in my head for a long
time
oh man it is
um is five nights at [__] boys in the uh
Fazbear fan verse initiative
the question you gotta ask yourself see
that's the question you have to ask
yourself is which fan games do you think
I think they're pulling the most
inspiration from
which fan games
oh man anyway
uh I should probably shut the [__] up
before I actually get myself in trouble
um no it's it's all good
I am very tired but I'm glad to have
been able to have this chat with you
guys I'm gonna go and I'm going to relax
and I'm going to prepare because
tomorrow is another day of film day of
filming for my own movie we've got a lot
of work left to go but at the end of
this week I will have a teaser trailer
for you
and I am incredibly excited and I hope
you can look forward to seeing this
movie
hopefully this year
maybe sooner than you think
is going to be
a wild one
is gonna be a wild one
anyway have a good day congratulations
to Ethan and all of the fighters Creator
Clash uh thank you so much for being
here and having patience with me
um just thank you
I am only able to do this stuff because
of you
and I I only really do this stuff for
you
uh I love making things and I I love
even more
you guys enjoying the things that I make
that's the greatest joy all of the the
hard work all of the arduous struggles
like when we release space all the hard
work
it was so worth it when that first day
when people were able to see it
and experience it move forward through
the story with it
I followed every path I could I watched
every stream I could of people watching
and I
love it
it makes it all worth it
I make it for me but I also make it for
you
thank you
I'll have some of them very soon
see you
in the next movie
and video videos coming back soon
bye-bye
bye
stop
here